ladies and gentlemen a comedian did you  hear this a comedian has won the  presidential election in Ukraine someone  in my profession finally became  president of a country fantastic that's  right he's the president of Ukraine is a  comedian he has already sold his  inaugural address as a one-hour Netflix  special and I looked up their  Constitution apparently the order of  succession in Ukraine goes comedian then  juggler then magician then Secretary of  Defense it's a nutty story though yeah  this guy yeah this story got a lot of  attention after hearing about it  Elizabeth Warren signed up for improv  classes crack hit yeah yeah what am i I  am a dentist  oh I'm excited for this guy I hope this  works out like everyone in comedy become  a world leader